Speaker 1: You can join The David Pakman Show
subreddit at David Pakman dot com slash Reddit
R e d i t nearly. What are we up to? It must
be about 33 34000 of our viewers and listeners
subscribe there. A couple of interesting posts and
discussions I spotted this morning. One is from
user DL 1943, who says, Does anyone know where I
can find explanations for the JFK Jr. stuff? I'm
totally fascinated by conspiracy theories and
always have been. Obviously, I do not believe
in QAnon or really any straight up conspiracies,
but I'd like to hear this whole JFK Jr. stuff laid
out by the people who believe it not regurgitated
through media articles. Does anyone know of any
publicly viewable sites where the Q people post
about this stuff or discuss it? Yeah. So listen,
my understanding is that a bunch of, I guess,
QAnon type people believe that JFK Jr., who was
killed in a plane crash in 1999, I think it was
is actually still alive. Some of them believed
that he was going to be running alongside Trump at
some point or was in 2020 in some kind of secret
way. Or, you know, there's a million different
iterations of this. And then others believe that
he was going to reappear, I guess, near the grassy
knoll in Dallas, Texas, a couple of days ago,
and they actually gathered there. That's sort of
like my best understanding of it, and I don't know
if there's any other specific reason why it's JFK
Jr. There was some confusion because a lot of the
very same people who believe that and are part of
QAnon are also anti-vax, and a really funny thing
seems to be in one. I don't remember if it was in
the comments on a rumble post or some right wing
enclave. I could tell from the comments that
there were people confused between this JFK Jr.
conspiracy and the fact that Bobby Kennedy Jr. is
anti-vax, and it was just like a whole confusion.
It was almost like Q ception. I would call it
where even the Q people were confused about the
concatenated conspiracy theories. OK. Anyway,
so that's my best understanding. But you know,
you might be able to find something clearer from
someone who actually believes a user MagSafe
departed posted to the subreddit y youngins at
the time. It was probable, but now it's now. It's
now we know it's victory y Yankees victory
needs to be taken seriously. And they write,
Youngkin had absolutely nothing to run on, nothing
of actual concrete substance, just culture,
war noises and a whole lot of old fashioned lies.
He's still ahead by over 100000 votes. He ran all
of the best, worst hits from ending critical
race theory, which doesn't exist in Virginia,
reinstating family values, a meaningless talking
point, attacking teachers and using things like
critical race theory as a blanket excuse to cut
funding meant to raise wages for teachers and the
idiots ate it up. I'm sure you've already seen the
bumpkin getting interviewed who said I don't care
much for CRT while on the other side of his mouth,
adding he has no clue what it is. It doesn't
matter. It's a non-issue. And it's one idiots.
I guess they mean cling to the reality is simple
with or without the B.S. culture, war noises,
these idiots we're all going to turn out in droves
for young and regardless, they're pissed. And
more importantly, they're galvanized. They've been
bashed over what's left of their brains multiple
times into thinking their voices weren't heard,
and now they're turning out in droves. It's
not yet known Democrats just didn't turn out
or if the numbers were not in their favor, but
this was a win for the GQ P, and if it really is
an indicator of what's to come next year, we're
in trouble. If Youngkin does emerge victorious,
which he did and an act of policies he's trying
to or tries to enact them, then the left needs
to shine a spotlight on it and use that to light
the necessary fires under our asses. Because the
GQ P has gone full stone age on us. And if people
remain apathetic, combined with voter suppression,
we're going to see a lot. This won't stay in
Virginia. This is absolutely correct. There's just
I have so little to add other than I did add on
to it in the first two segments on today's show.
The answer is not always run further to the left.
The answer is not always run further to the to the
middle. It depends on the race. There's not a one
size fits all approach, but the one size fits all
approach that the right is implementing is the one
we have to fight. And that is fear and anger over
things that are completely untrue, that are being
exaggerated or misstated or simply misunderstood
by Republican voters. And it's really, really
hard to fight that. I don't have the answer. I
proposed a couple of possibilities earlier, but I
don't have the answer. But I think this assessment
is spot on anybody saying anybody downplaying the
effect or the significance of Tuesday's elections
for Democrats for 2022, even 2024. You could have.
A big wake up call, it's going to be very ugly.
Join the discussion at David
Pakman dot com slash Reddit.